well as travel picks up so does shopping
shopping centers and
malls like town square are seeing a
boost in shoppers that's a very
different picture
from this time last year eight news now
reporter victoria saha shows us
how business is booming again places
like town square are bouncing back
up again after a lonely year take a look
behind me this is just a regular weekday
afternoon here
with folks out and about
we need this i feel good about this
today town square feels alive again with
shoppers hitting up their favorite
stores
well it's getting closer to normal i
don't think i'm going to feel completely
normal
until i can lose the mass though the
mask mandate is still
in place it seems like folks are more
than happy to wear them to get closer to
a little sense of normalcy
we came one time i don't remember one
but it was empty
it was like a ghost town long time
friends vera miller and linda falk
are both vaccinated they say it's the
vaccines that are bringing people back
out
more people in stores by far the
staff the people working in the stores
are seen happy and friendly
business owners also say the recent
stimulus track is helping them with a
boost in foot
traffic we have seen the result of
people getting
some expendable income again which has
been really a huge help for us
the month of march was our strongest
month since we've been open it's a huge
relief for owners of jacinta boutique
they had to shut down
after their grand opening you know it
really feels to me like people have just
woken up from a long
long long nap you can see people
starting to walk around with
smiles on their faces even under the
mask you can see it in their eyes
bringing the long lost energy back to
local businesses
many of the people we spoke to today are
hoping that this is just the beginning
of things picking back up here
reporting in town square victoria saha 8
news now
well to encourage more shoppers there is
a scavenger hunt for
10 stores in town square now you have to
find each store
and go inside and then you have a chance
of winning 500
gift card pretty cool right